so we're going to go to minnesota where
the push for justice and the death of
dante wright is really raging there
former brooklyn center police officer
kim potter will be in court for the very
first time today
she is charged with second-degree
manslaughter after killing
wright during a routine traffic stop
there were clashes last night in
brooklyn center between the protesters
throwing things
and police using tear gas to disperse
the crowd but most of the day's events
we have to say were peaceful including
a vigil for dante wright where he was
shot omar villafranca is in the brooklyn
center
omar good morning to you
good morning things are calm now behind
me as you can see and despite the
mayor's calls for peaceful protests
there was some
unrest last night but now the mayor says
that law enforcement officials
are working to identify what they call
agitators because he says he knows
there's a lot of people who are coming
here
to protest peacefully your voices
have been heard brooklyn center mayor
mike elliott urged calm in the community
following the announcement the charges
of second-degree manslaughter had been
brought against former police officer
kim potter there is
nothing i can say or do
that will bring dante back or ease your
grief
his death will not go in vain potter a
26-year veteran of the force
had been training another officer sunday
when they pulled right over for an
expired tag
they discovered wright had an
outstanding warrant for a misdemeanor
weapons charge
and tried to arrest him when wright
resisted the former police chief said
potter thought she grabbed her taser
but instead pulled her glock nine
millimeter handgun with her right hand
an investigator examining potter's duty
belt after the shooting
said her taser was on her left side and
her handgun was on the right
as seen in this past photo according to
the criminal complaint
the taser was yellow with a black grip
and set in a straight draw position
meaning the defendant would have to use
her left hand to draw the taser out of
its holster
a taser also weighs about eight ounces
while a loaded handgun
is about two pounds manslaughter two is
the least
she should get the least
possibly more civil rights activist al
sharpton
praised the decision to charge potter if
she didn't know in 26 years
the difference in size and weight
of a gun as opposed to a taser
then how was she a veteran in policing
potter is now out on bail and if
convicted she could face a maximum of
10 years in prison and a 20 000 fine now
we talked to use of force expert greg
meyer and he said in the last 20 years
i'm going to get this right 18 cases
where officers have confused their
weapons and fire that suspects have
happened
including this case and of those cases
eight officers were charged
two cases are still pending including
potters
tony shows how rare this really is omar
thank you very much